good morning believe nation today's
message is always try to improve over to
you Louis CK not about not killing it's
about doing the best show that you can
do and it's about staying at a at the at
the edge of your ability of doing it
better I want to do a better show every
time I'm on stage I mean part of it is
that I want to keep I want what I do to
keep getting better unless you think
you're the best comedian that ever could
poss like your perfect crystalline
diamond of a comedian they couldn't
possibly be improved upon every molecule
has been compressed together to the
point is no air in it right your VAT
you're a black hole of a comic that
can't there's just no room for
improvement I you know you folded the
samurai sword a thousand times and just
can't fold anymore no so you got to keep
trying I mean I think a lot of people in
show business in comedy even especially
are very lazy and they just sort of
think that you just get up there and
then you wait for your manager to get
you a better one a little better shot
but it's it's something you gotta really
to me I mean for me I just want to keep
working at it and it would yeah I
wouldn't like it if I stopped trying
really hard it isn't a neurosis like oh
jeez I hope they like me it's this is
what I do I gotta do it really really
well i think this message is really
important for entrepreneurs because if
you want to build a successful business
than what you should be looking at is
was I better than yesterday right did I
do something better in my business that
I grow as an entrepreneur or as a person
as a human being compared to where I was
yesterday and I think it can be really
helpful in two ways one you want to
continually be challenged like part of
why you started a business was to
challenge yourself was to grow because
you didn't like working a nine-to-five
job because you wanted to be your own
boss and it's never enough just to
create something amazing you want to
continue to build if you are if you stop
innovating in your company in your
YouTube channel on your business if you
stop that innovation process you start
to get bored and it happens to a lot of
entrepreneurs you
in one year two years three years in
they start to get bored with their
businesses because they're doing the
same thing that they were doing when
they started and they're not innovating
anymore and as you change and evolve as
a person your business needs to change
and evolve with you as well and we get
locked into our patterns and habits of
the past and the things that made you
success in the past become chains that
prevent you from growing and being great
going forward so you look at my channel
as an example since you guys are YouTube
fans it's changed a lot from when I
started go back to what my first videos
look like and compare it to now it's
3,000 videos later not just me getting
better on camera and maybe having more
wisdom or better points to share with
you but the structure that we've done
the way that we shoot the videos are the
different types of series I'm never you
know as much as I love the top 10 series
and i love the NSO series and i love the
lunch and earn series and every series
on the channel i'm always looking to
integrate to add something new to change
it up always because if I don't have
something new a new product that I'm
working on I get bored and I get bored
you can place it then you start looking
for other projects somewhere else and so
instead of looking for distraction
projects think about in your business
how can you make something better today
and be better than you were yesterday
the second side of that coin for me is
comparing yourself to other people a lot
of people look at somebody else and say
well I want to be like them and because
you haven't gotten to that same level of
success you get discouraged if you're
starting YouTube channel you might look
to my channel or somebody else you look
up to and you look at them and you look
at how good they are natural are
comfortable they are on camera say why
can't I be like that well I've had three
thousand videos under my belt right it
takes some time to get used to it to
build that muscle up to get comfortable
and to have good points and be able to
deliver a message on camera if you look
back to my first videos I sucked at the
start and as I've said it's taken me
seven hundred videos before I wasn't
embarrassed by my own videos I couldn't
watch my own video 700 videos oh my God
look at that my name is
hi Michael the content is still great
but there's no passion look at me and a
lot of you guys you're 5 10 20 videos
into your channel hating on what you've
done or meanwhile like at that point
you're you're you're way ahead of where
I was at that point and so you're
comparing your start to somebody else's
middle or did somebody else as close to
their end and that's not a fair
comparison and so what you want to do is
just be better than you were yesterday
make sure there's always growth because
that keeps you happy and then always
striving to be better so that your
product will be better your customers
will get more value you'll be able to
have a bigger impact on the world so the
question today today is how are you
trying to improve yourself leave it in
the comments below I'm going to join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events press